dominique pradalié bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous c'est donc une
conférence en soutien à julian assange
pourrait vous nous en dire plus eh bien
écoutez julian assange est un symbole
mondial pour la liberté d'expression et
la liberté d'information et il est
maintenant un symbole mondial du
confinement puisque notre malheureux
confrère subi des méthodes de
confinement depuis maintenant presque 8
ans et où il est poursuivi par les états
unis d'amérique notamment pour avoir
informé le monde entier de des
dispositions prises par l'administration
américaine dans la guerre pour limiter
la liberté d'expression et pour cacher
ce que toutes les armées du monde
veulent qu acheter c'est à dire ce qui
est
elle commencera d'inacceptable contre
les libertés humaines
julian assange est en grand danger nous
lui avons nous syndicats journalistes
français adressé une lettre le 11 avril
dernier puisque ça fait exactement un an
qu'il est acquis les confiner à abel
morte à la prison anglaise confinés dans
des conditions qui font craindre pour sa
santé et nous souhaitons que ce courrier
lui rappelle que le monde entier des
journalistes libres le soutien alors
vous parlais justement de ses conditions
de détention sont elles plus
préoccupante du fait de la pandémie du
corona lire selon vous bien évidemment
elles sont beaucoup plus inquiétante aux
deux raisons la première c'est qu'elle
la joute du stress et des risques
d'attraper le virus quand on est dans
une prison où les méthodes de sécurité
sont bien connus pour empêcher des
tenues s'évader mais pas pour empêcher
les virus de rentrer ça c'est une
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que en plus de
ce stress
julian assange peut craindre qu'il soit
oublié de tous et de toutes c'est pour
ça que nous travaillons ce soir nous
organisons cette soirée deux mondial
avec la fédération internationale des
journalistes qui est la plus grande
l'instance de représentation des
journalistes dans le monde
nous organisons cette soirée mondiale
pour empêcher qu'il soit oublié pour les
essayer de l'aider à retrouver un peu de
courage
un mois avant la dernière audience
prévue qui doit décider ou non de son
extradition vers les etats-unis
dominique pradalié secrétaire générale
du snj
le syndicat national des journalistes
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci